you wanna it's over what actually gave
you that impression
Chase has been in the wind for a week
he's picking us off one by one who
better than no such that those closest
to you they did suffer who know since I
put the hot array my father's rocks it
was all based on oh hi
nothing ever really dies there always
echoes you'll learn that's enough
I'm going to do whatever it takes to see
the scene and that created him and to
think you were going to be me although
we were trained by the same teacher we
have unfinished little were mistakes I
know John I'm on the side that's gonna
go chase away I'm sorry not that I told
you everyone that you care about soccer
[Music]
breacher quad I'm glad you came
you
[Music]
holy crap everybody arrow finale trailer
so if you weren't sure what's going on
in this this is for all of the five
episodes this has footage from
everything from episode 19 which is
coming back next week through episode 23
the actual finale so that's why you see
a bunch of scenes on the island and you
see him opening the prison the dead
stroke is in underground and bringing
him his armor back take it I'm glad you
came back and we got a bit of a
clarification on the new Bennet
participation in the episode so he did
this weird thing where he's like I'm not
in the episode why is everybody saying
I'm in the episode but Marc Guggenheim
was welcoming him back so it sounds like
what's happening is is it's going to be
a different actor underneath the armor
and it'll just be him doing the voice
because he's stuck in New Zealand
working on another TV show and just
couldn't physically come to the set
unless he was completely lie but it
sounds like he's only just doing the
voice as we hear in the trailer but you
see Nyssa al Ghul has come back the
daughters of Rachele Gore going to go at
it Talia versus Nyssa going to be so
awesome you see some red hot canary on
canary action and then you see Yao Fei
himself the man from season one
appearing is a hallucination to Oliver
so there's so much awesome stuff going
in this I'm gonna have to go
frame-by-frame just because the way they
cut it they cut a whole bunch of footage
into this so if you're new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get
everything there's a new round of the
flash ring giveaway all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber leave a
comment on this video arrow has been lit
this last season and it gives you an
idea for the momentum that they have
going into season six and quick
clarifications they have up to couple
actors to series regular the actresses
playing Dinah Drake the new black canary
in wild dog are both series regulars for
season six so that means they'll be in
most of the episodes but they're also
bringing back Katie Cassidy as the black
siren character she will also be a
series regular but we don't know exactly
how they're going to use her because
it's not like they're going to have two
Canaries on Team arrow so it sounds like
she's going to be one of the big builds
of the season but like Malcolm Merlyn
comes back during the trailer maybe she
teams up with him because he's always
going to be a big arrow character we
don't know a whole lot about who the
villain of season six is going to be but
like you see Kovar on the island here
which i think is awesome at least it
seems like he's on the island
anytime it looks like they're fighting
in the Vancouver woods you just have to
assume that they're fighting on Lian Yu
just because that's where that location
is there's very few times they've ever
fought in woods where it hasn't been on
the island but what's slowly happening
here is that the past in the present are
slowly converging on Lian Yu like he's
chasing down kovar in the flashbacks
that fight looks like it takes into the
island in then in present-day he's
chasing down prometheus that also looks
like it takes into the island so it
almost sounds like there's going to be
two big boss fights happening in the
past and in the present on Lian Yu in
the finale the one in the present is
going to be the one the death stroke
suits up for because in the past he met
Deathstroke when he first came to the
island and when he's coming to the
island in the past in this season is
actually at the end of that five year
run so he's already had all that season
two drama with Deathstroke
he's already blown up the Amazo
Deathstroke has swum off and escaped
he's already had that big adventure with
Sarah so I'll try to explain that when
we get to that episode because the past
timeline on the island is a little bit
fuzzy especially if you haven't been
watching arrow for the last couple of
seasons but if you have any friends that
haven't been watching this show make
sure you sit their asses down and tell
them to watch the last couple of
episodes this season but like I said
some of this footage is from the next
couple of episodes it looks like they
don't make it back to Leanne you in the
past and in the present until like the
last two episodes or so so as is the
tradition typically they stretch like a
really big story over the last couple of
episodes so some of these characters
like Nyssa al Ghul will probably come
back before episode 23 they're not going
to like Jim everything into the finale
but there is going to be a giant team-up
and there's a big rumor that Roy may
have also come back for the finale too
but he's nowhere in this trailer so just
expect a couple surprises there's just a
couple rumors that haven't been
confirmed yet the other thing you may
have noticed is Cody Rhodes is back to
remember his character went like all
solomon grundy so he was great when he
came on at the beginning of the season
it's only going to be even crazier now
the thing I love about wrestlers in real
life is that they're great when it comes
to doing stunts more Island stuff though
it looks like Anatolia is the one that
drops him off because he doesn't have
the wookie long hair they actually
posted a picture of this from Baja
on the scene it's totally crazy so
anybody's fair game from season one to
come back but just there are dead people
that will appear as hallucinations like
Yao Fei there'll be a lot of other big
characters that'll appear physically in
present-day so the other big thing here
is that we see black siren earth to
Laurel finally meeting with Quentin they
said that that would happen eventually
and it's going to be crazy because he's
never met her in person before so just
expect whatever craziness happens
between them because Quentin's probably
going to go nuts that it'll carry into
season 6 and that'll be part of
Quentin's arc as well dealing with the
idea of this other version of his
daughter that's alive in is totally evil
so I don't know if they're going to try
and do some sort of redemption arc for
black siren but I think they're going to
try and let Katie Cassidy have as much
fun as possible just being this
incredibly complicated version of Laurel
which I'm all for because there's a lot
of criticism of the way they wrote the
Laurel character going back to season
one because it took them a couple
seasons to figure the show out so one of
the casualties of that is a lot of like
the crazy melodrama that they gave her
storyline in season 1 just stuff that
just did not pan out so this is just a
way to reimagine the character we'll see
how it goes I know a lot of people
really like the Laurel character there
are a lot of people that really hated
her so we'll see what this turn does for
that and we finally get Artemis back I
know everybody's wondering what's going
on with her character she isn't
confirmed for season 6 so it looks like
they deal with her
maybe if she survives and usually they
do let characters like this survive
because she's actually been pretty
interesting to stick her in the island
with Slade after this is all done
but I'm secretly hoping that Oliver lets
Deathstroke escape or he escapes on his
own so maybe if Artemis is going to
continue to be evil in season 6 she'll
escape with Deathstroke and that's where
she'll reappear whenever they bring
those characters back but it's going to
be so awesome I'm so happy with the way
they cut this and all the stuff that
they're doing like they are bringing it
so if anybody wondered if they have any
chance of making it to season 7 I think
those chances shot up a thousand percent
just based on this footage but they'd
actually been doing a really good job in
prometheus has been one of the best
villains best performances by the actor
from a villain that they've ever had
next to destro so let me know who are
your favorite arrow villain and who
you want them to bring back in season
six because just like damian darhk--
even though there's like a big bad that
all of our kills at the end of the
season they find ways of bringing those
characters back so there's always
chances for big villains in past seasons
to become part of the Suicide Squad
because it kind of seems like they're
reforming that slowly in the background
that's all speculation I just I think
they're going to bring the Suicide Squad
back before arrow goes off the air in
the next couple of years but I almost
forgot the actor that plays kovar Dolph
Lundgren himself has been cast as the
king of zeboiim and movie so that's not
going to be happening for a couple years
they're still making the Aquaman movie
right now but they are very few times
when you see an actor from the CW
universe making it into the DC EU but
obviously it's a different character so
there's not going to be any connection
between them and just a heads up I found
out that NBC is blocking the Krypton
trailer worldwide all over YouTube all
over the Internet so I still think that
it's a Studio Lee but this happens every
once in a while but they could have done
that immediately so I think they were
just gauging fan reactions so what will
probably happen is when they announce
whether or not the TV series is actually
going to air like they just in the pilot
they haven't confirmed whether or not
it's actually going to become a TV
series then they'll release some
official footage but if you wonder why
you're unable to watch the Krypton
trailer that I've posted it is because
NBC is like please don't post this
anymore like we're happy that everybody
got to see it but we don't want this out
there right now so it's not that big a
deal we'll probably hear more about it
later this year so what's going to
happen next is is there's a whole bunch
of trailers that drop so I'll try to get
to them as fast as possible there's Thor
and Black Panthers there's a Rick and
Morty VR game trailer that I'll post and
I know you're wondering where's the
flash trailer like they did this for
arrow where's the flash version of this
they're probably not done making CG but
if they post a flash trailer I'll
totally do a video for it
congratulations to last week's giveaway
winner rapid response please private
message me so I can get your contact
details you can click here to watch that
cloak-and-dagger trailer and you can
click here for brand new flash season 3
thank you so much for watching since I 5
I'll see you guys in the next video